for you this morning Friday evening you
can celebrate the holidays with a
cherished Southern Nevada tradition of
course we're talking about the magical
forest over an opportunity Village
opening up for the first time for the
holiday season and there is so much to
see and so much to do oh Christmas
lights Santa himself someone's excited I
am excited I just switched uh I know but
Candace loves Christmas too so we're
gonna go out live to her she's at the
magical forest oh and look you did get
heather up there hi Candace
hi good morning guys good morning folks
yes I am on top of the Avalanche one of
the many rides here at the magical
forest as was mentioned So Many Lights
two million lights yes two million
lights you can see here this is one of
the rides there's other rides lots of
foods oh really just like a really fun
family event or a date night I'm joined
by opportunity Villages Heather Davis
tell us a little bit about what makes
this year so special we've been talking
about that a little bit you know it's
just the energy there's extra lights
there's more sponsors it's just a
beautiful time to come out and really
get in the holiday spirit and you're
getting in the holiday spirit while
giving back to the community tell us
about that so every penny you spend here
goes to support the people we serve here
in the community that we serve with
disabilities and their families who love
them I love it Heather thank you so much
for all the work you do in the community
and you guys can enjoy this yourself for
the first time this season on Friday at
5 30 plenty of time to come down here of
course it's all the way up until
December 31st okay I'm gonna give you a
sneak peek of what you can enjoy here
again if you find all the details on our
website newsnow.com I'm going downstairs
Happy Thanksgiving you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
well Ryan Candace well done
[Music]
I love it lots of fun there